one thing i've noticed is that one of
the ways in which i know that i am
finding truths out is that problem is
solved for good that's exactly right i
don't have to revisit that same problem
again because that problem is solved for
good both my internal state and my
external state quote unquote improve
they change improve is a big word so the
more they change internally i'm quieter
and externally my life is less
complicated you have brought up a
seminal point which is it is not about
the journey it absolutely is about the
destination you want to get to the point
where you don't have it anymore
you aren't looking for treatments you're
looking for a cure there is a
destination it isn't about spending the
next 90 years getting assaulted and then
feeling better getting assaulted and
putting tiger bomb on it it is about
wanting to get over it
destination and journeys that's another
lie it's not about journeys it's about
destinations now destinations require
journeys but everything that you do in
your life is defined by the destination
the moment that you leave your house
every single day you have a destination
and the destination creates the avenue
this is one of those social lies where
everyone says about the journey the
journey is the reward
yeah the journey is the thing that
you're actually on that's where you are
right now but if you don't get to a
destination you sort of wasted your time
well if there was no destination no one
would begin any journey
if there was no compulsion to arrive
anywhere then nobody wouldn't begin any
kind of journey at all it is just that
most people's destination is the
prescription wearing the orange colored
robe and then sitting in front of the
incense and having the self-image that
i'm a yogi and that i am meditating and
i am doing all the spiritual things and
that becomes a destination in itself
that i have achieved that self-image
where i view myself that way
so what is a worthy destination
oh there is no worthy it is not about
enforcing rules there are no rules rules
are to be avoided at all costs if one is
sincere because wherever there's a rule
there's insincerity it's like stoicism
it's a rule it can't go anywhere it's
more self-image creation
everything begins with the truth what is
the truth the truth is that in a human
being's life he has problems that's the
truth
in a human being's life he has specific
problems some problems that are more
acute for him than for his neighbor his
most acute problems are his living
reality they're not abstract they're not
spiritual they are in his face and he
lives in that every single day that is
where to begin
so one begins very concretely with one's
own problems there are real problems
that everybody faces and if you have a
genuine desire to solve these problems
once and for all
the way to do them is not to follow some
routine or build up some image of the
person who solves problems it's to
examine them for the truth no matter how
unpopular or how untransmissible or
unexplainable it might be and if you
look for the truth and you find it
you'll know you've found it when you've
solved the problem
and if we go back to zero for a second
zero is the understanding
that problems can be solved forever
society believes in journeys society
believes in endless treatments forever
practice practice practice practice
practice forever
when the whole game has been set up
to practice forever then there is no
conclusion there is no arrival of
anything there's a way for people to see
that if you look at how we think about
spirituality and solving problems
internally
it is considered to be oh i'm just going
to work on it forever i'm going to go
see a therapist forever i'm going to
meditate forever i'm going to read
forever i'm going to talk to a counselor
or to a coach forever i'm going to work
on it i'm on the path i'm on the journey
but if you go into very practical things
like making money nobody says i'm going
to work forever no they're like i want
to make a pile of money right if i'm
starting a company i want the company to
be successful i want the company to go
public or to get acquired or generate so
much cash flow that while i'm still
alive i can spend that cash
in the money-making context we're
extremely practical we want to make that
money while we're still young enough and
alive enough to spend it but in the
internal context we get all spiritual
and start talking about maybe the next
life maybe in heaven or in hell or in my
reincarnated life or i'm just going to
keep doing my self-work and my
self-improvement until the day i die
it's considered acceptable to never
arrive at a destination
there's a very simple truth
as to how to arrive at getting over your
problems without having to lift a finger
you cut my ears it's all about exposure
if a person sat on his couch
for the next 50 years
his internal environment from his mind
to his brain everything within him
is a direct resonance
it's like a tuning fork it responds to
the inputs same as a microphone
if that human is exposed to truth on a
regular basis
his ears don't even have to hear it
consciously something inside of him
will internalize that truth and that
will become his new norm a human being
becomes his environment and that is why
it's absolutely critical to savagely and
surgically arrange one's environment in
a way
that is in accordance with where he
wants to go
no one does that if a person is exposed
to truth on a regular basis now not
prescription it's got to be straight
truth
then that becomes his norm that becomes
the way that he thinks his brain begins
to rewire itself there isn't a single
amount of work that needs to be done
there isn't a single amount of
psychotherapy that needs to be done no
medications
the human body treats itself it all
depends upon the input
it is all about one thing and one thing
only exposure you become
that which you are most consistently
exposed to
in a modern context the people who are
very interested in
truth and in conquering the mind and
internal freedom
tend to coalesce on
reading the same books
thinking about the same things listen
the same podcast talking the same people
and even though prescriptions don't work
and no book is going to make you
conquer the mind and listening to any
podcast is not going to give you
internal freedom eventually at some
point it does soak in
you're attracted to what you want to be
and as you immerse yourself in it you
have no choice but to become that over
time it's like in wealth creation if you
want to start a company you go to
silicon valley or you go to a pool of
entrepreneurs and you spend enough time
around them you hang around the tech
business long enough and you'll be in
the tech business you hang around a
bunch of techies you'll be talking tech
all day so we're naturally drawn to
certain things and if we can immerse
ourselves in them it creates
inevitability
to the future
and to take it to the next level it's
about titrating that environment because
any environment from silicon valley to
anywhere else while it has the benefits
it will also have the detriments it's
about titrating out all that is not
wanted
and titrating in all that is it can very
much be
fine-tuned like a buffet
here's the situation
you guys have observed these guys for a
year
you know these guys
right
uh the thing is that
our our behavior patterns
and who we are as people
is very heavily influenced
by the people who are our friends
okay
so if my friends are better than me
i will get better
if my friends are worse than me i'll get
worse there's a gravitational pull both
ways
and so
if you want to have a better life
you have to focus on friends who are
better than you
one of the things you need to do
is you need to become friends with them
for two reasons one is they're going to
be very rich
it's always good to have rich friends
you agree
always good to have rich friends it's
not a it's a it's a it's an important
thing the second is
that
you live with these guys you're in the
same class with that you should observe
them
so
get to know them well and see how they
spend the day
and then you ask yourself can i be like
them
can i spend my day like them
so the thing is at this age
16 17 at this age
you are like wet clay
it can be molded it can be changed
your behavior patterns can be changed at
my age
they cannot be changed
okay so if you want to make changes in
terms of how you are and who you are
now is the time
and so the best way to make those
changes is to focus on role models so
these two guys are great role models and
please focus on them
congratulations
don't forget about me when you become a
billionaire okay please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
you